[Applaudissements]
du diable on est tous en fête avec
christophe dechavanne sauf et nora qui
se fera au lit on vous verra ça dans un
instant pour le moment les chéris big
lots et audi sont avec nous alors big
flo et oli
je vous le dis en écriture en musique ce
sont vraiment des génies voir un loup
dit et il adore en plus sa télé c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont avec nous et vous
leur avez proposé des mots ici les
chroniqueurs juste avant il y avait le
mot vu le football une tartiflette
casquette biscotte maman fatou
métabolisme freudien coupe et dont
tartiflette et casquettes c'était donc
les téléspectateurs sur twitter qu'ils
ont proposés vous allez nous faire donc
c'est cette semaine au freestyle
ouais c'est comme un free dom et au
niveau musique
[Applaudissements]
la vente du temps de tankessé d'être
cool s'est fait pas que sinon le vieux
qui essaient de checker mais qui sait un
comme ça son ca sens où les jeunes alors
les chéris alors vous allez dites moi on
dirait sans déconner on dirait qu'ils
vont donner les résultats des primaires
écoutez ici à solférino pour l'instant
martine aubry et tonte est alors qu'est
ce qui se passe on dit bah quoi sert
votre avis la terrasse coupe ou et du
rouleau mais en fait on a écrit dessus
tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi c'est moi parce que je
croyais que vous retenez tout dans la
tête
oui je me suis dit ça va c'est que c'est
ton émission le les concepts et où tu
dois les connaître tout ça c'est écoutez
je ne sais pas du tout ce qui nous est
très beau très beau ordinateur attention
c'est parti
vous avez passé tous les mois ok cristal
en direct de touche pas à mon poste
on y va et précis hier cyril devrais je
suis prêt 1
on m'a demandé d'écrire un texte en cinq
minutes chrono
alors je me suis boulet besoin
d'instruments et fêter la sono ensuite à
la télé je vous présente le hip hop le
frère et elle mon mec totti personnes
wifi lit de biscottes
au milieu de tous ces vieux je suis
seule avec mes baskets delormeau a
tellement la grosse tête qui peut plus
mettre de casquette je prends les mecs
j'ai l'impression de passer un oral et
tous mes potes en bas rêve de finir en
couple avec enora hier jean michel maire
est encore parti faire la fête
j'ai un recul de montagnards qui veulent
la tartiflette si je foutais la merde et
j'écrivais même à l'école ils touchent
des boues jean michel maire mais lui n'a
jamais fait de football n'ont pas de
temps alors vite je fais bouger le stylo
elle veut je place le moscow dhien à
l'épreuve de philo j'ai tellement de
flou quand je prends le mac menemy
agonise au final je crois que la musique
et danse mon métabolisme j'ai une tête
bizarre way le rap c'est mon seul atout
j'ai fait le tour du monde recherche de
mafate ou depuis la télé j'avais promis
que j'en ferai ma tête j'entends des
voix comme jeanne d'arc ou marc-antoine
le bret j'ai l'impression d'être en
cours qui flambent la même pour parler
et si vous faites deux millions ce soir
c'est grâce à ma mère l'a prévenu tout
le quartier
le mec a dit mme ovules
question qu'il a 12 6 mais je garde mon
calme quand jean luc lemoine goodies et
dit si le texte est nul
au moins il aura été main juste avant la
fin j'en profite
coucou maman
[Applaudissements]
mariama ba ba ba ba ba ba et j'adorais
pour réviser pas pu lâcher
messieurs
c'est l'inversé ça fait du bien ça fait
du bien tout ça